[Music]
et can confirm heather locklear was
arrested on Sunday night on charges of
misdemeanor battery on an officer and
emergency personnel police responded to
a 911 family member and the 56 year old
was reportedly heavily intoxicated when
they arrived
Locklear reportedly punched a responding
deputy then reportedly kicked an EMT
while being placed on a gurney she was
placed on a twenty thousand dollar bail
her next court date is scheduled for
Tuesday at the Ventura County Superior
Court the incident comes just days after
the actress was hospitalized following
an emergency call to the police a source
close to Locklear claimed to et that the
family called the police after she was
quote acting erratically and threatened
to kill herself the source also told et
that after months of working with a
sober coach the family believes Locklear
is no longer sober quote her family
wants nothing more for her than to be
checked into a facility until she
finally truly is clean and sober the
Melrose Place star was also arrested in
February for an incident at home
involving her boyfriend Chris Heiser
Locklear who is facing four counts of
misdemeanor battery on an officer and
one charge of resisting or obstructing
an officer from the incident entered a
not guilty plea in April
you
[Music]